هذا وقال المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي
دانييل هاري ان الجيش يواصل التحقيقات
الداخليه بشان هجمات السابع من اكتوبر
مؤكدا انها ليست بديله عن اي تحقيقات
اخرى سنواصل التحقيقات الداخليه بشان
هجمات السابع من اكتوبر الماضي تشارك فيها
قيادات حاليه وسابقه في الجيش
وسنبلغك شفافيه عند الانتهاء منها و
تحقيقات الجيش تهدف الى تحسين اداء القوات
وليست بديلا عن تحقيقات
اخرى من تلابيب ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
محمد خيري ما جرى في مجلس الوزراء ما زالت
تداعياته قائمه يعني هجوم نادر على
نتنياهو من عضو في مجلس الحرب بيني جانز و
انضم اليه ايضا ير لابيت زعيم المعارضه
كيف تناول الاعلام الاسرائيلي هذه
الخلافات هل هنالك اشارات او استنباطات
واستخلاص بانها تقصر في عمر هذه
الحكومه يعني كي توضع الامور في سياقاتها
الطبيعيه هذه الخلافات ليست جديده ولكنها
ازدادت بحده منذ اليوم الاول للحرب هناك
من كان ينادي في اسرائيل ويقول حقيقه ان
حكومه نتنياهو غير قادره على اداره هذه
الحرب ودعت في بالفور رغم بدء الحرب في
الاول في اليوم الاول والثاني والثالث الى
عزل بنيامين نتنياهو كي تستطيع اسرائيل
البدء في هذه الحرب فعليا الخلافات واسعه
جدا اليوم الصوت الذي يعلو في اسرائيل هو
صوت الخلافات السياسيه اذا ما جئنا الى
تصريحات كافه الوزراء وقيادات الجيش
فالحديث يدور عن المصالح السياسيه جميعهم
تحدثوا عن المصالح السياسيه لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وهذا حديث قديم جديد و
لكن هناك بعض التفسيرات تشير الى ان
الوزراء الذين هاجموا قيادات الجيش وخاصه
رئيس هيئه الاركان هيرتس ليفي خلال جلسه
المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه
والسياسيه يوم امس كانوا بالفعل هم يريدون
وقف مثل بدء مثل هذا التحقيق ليس لان
التحقيق يعني س سيتك شف عنه اخطاء معينه
او تحقيقات مع قيادات الجيش ربما لانهم
يخشون كما تقول مثلا صحيفه دعوت حر نوت
بان يشكل هذا ضغطا على المستوى السياسي
ايضا في اسرائيل من اجل تشكيل لجنه تحقيق
مع المستوى السياسي وقيادات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالتالي سيحرج هذا الامر رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الذي
يعني يعد من ابرز القاده الاسرائيليين
الذين لا يزالون حتى اليوم يرفضون
الاعتراف وتحمل المسؤوليه بالفشل عما حصل
يوم السابع من اكتوبر وهذا بحد ذاته ايضا
يثير الكثير من من الجدل ايه ضد والكثير
من الغضب ضد حكومه نتنياهو هذا الجدل في
المستوى السياسي والعسكري والامني ينضاف
اليه ايضا الحراك في الشارع الاسرائيلي
الاسبوع الماضي شهدت تل ابيب هنا مظاهره
يعني شارك فيها عدد كبير الالاف من
الاسرائيليين لاول مره بهذا الحجم منذ بدء
الحرب وهي هذه المظاهره التي طالبت باقاله
بنيامين نتنياهو كما قلنا هذه الاضخم كانت
منذ بدء الحرب وقد امتدت مظاهرات الى عدد
من المدن الاسرائيليه اذا واضح جدا ان
اسرائيل امام مفترق طرق ان اسرائيل امام
الكثير من الخلافات وذلك في ظل الحديث عن
بدء المرحله الثالثه من الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه وكذلك في ظل زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن وكذلك
الضغوطات الدوليه والضغوطات التي يمارسها
تمارسها الاداره الامريكيه ل ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل بدء المرحله الثالثه
ومن اجل ومن اجل مد قطع غزه بالمساعدات
الانسانيه وكذلك ايضا يجب ان نذكر المحكمه
التي يعني ستبدا في تداول جرائم الحرب
الاسرائيليه محكمه العدل الدوليه اخيرا
دعني دعني اشير الى ان الخلافات ايضا بدات
على مستوى اخر اخذت منحى اخر اليوم طالبت
عائلات رهائن اسرائيليين كانوا في احد
المنازل في كيبوتس بي ايري بالتحقيق طالبت
الجيش بالتحقيق في قضيه قصف احدى الدباب
الاسرائيليه لهذا المنزل رغم وجود
اسرائيليين بالتالي ادى الى مقتلهم كما
يبدو او هذا ما سيظهر خلال التحقيق الذي
قد يبدا قريبا